Speaker 1: Let's hear from the most important
people to the David Pakman show the viewers
and the listeners. We like to take calls
via discord. You can join the discord at
David Pakman dot com slash discord. It's an
incredible thing. We are going to start calls
today. How about tristin from washington. Tristin
from washington. Welcome to the David Pakman show.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 4: This.
Hello? David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 4: Oh, good heavens.
To Betsy on a racetrack. Right.
Such an honor to start the show today.
Speaker 1: The honor is all mine, sir.
Speaker 4: Thank you so much. So a couple of
things. One, I've called your show a few times
before, and one of the last time you called, I was
in Oregon. I am now moved to the Seattle area and
we had discussed on a previous call a chocolate
babka. And I am happy to report since I have moved
here, I've found three different Jewish delis in
the area and I'm very happy. I hope that I can
compare the two and get back to you. Have you been
to Seattle? Do you know about any of these places?
Speaker 1: No, I haven't. But, you know,
I follow very closely J. Kenji Lopez Alt,
who does now live in Seattle, and he seems
to post some great food spots in Seattle.
The food scene seems to be quite lively there.
Speaker 4: Oh, it's. It's very exquisite. I, I
really can't wait to try everything that it has to
offer. It's. It's going to be a great experience.
And I can't wait to give you my report once I've
experienced the culinary traditions of Seattle.
Speaker 1: Now, let me ask you one thing.
The chocolate Bob. Yeah. That you've seen
around there, they're not putting
chocolate chips on top, are they?
Speaker 4: Well, I. So I just moved here. I
haven't gotten a chance to actually go down
there. Like I said last time, the only
bad guy I've tried was the Trader Joe's.
And they do put chocolate chips on.
Speaker 1: They're actually very,
very suspicious about chocolate chips
on top of the babka. Okay, that's my
advice. But report back when you know more.
Speaker 4: I will definitely do so. Can't
wait to do it. Next question. Sure. I have a
bit of a quirky guy. I have quirky beliefs and
I've been I want to take you back to the founding
of our country. Yeah. 222 years ago when judicial
review was was established by the Supreme
Court. Basically, they gave themselves that
power. And because the Supreme Court has been
in the news so much and I realize this is not
actually going to happen anytime soon, but I just
kind of wanted to get your opinion, do you think?
That overturning the precedent of judicial
review would actually solve a lot of the
problems that the court has caused for us. And
following that, do you think what sort of system,
if you David Pakman where the founding
fathers of this country, what system for
the court do you think you would establish?
Speaker 1: You know, I don't. On the second
question, I don't know. That's really more of
a question for a legal scholar. I'm sure you'll
find all sorts of random political people
who will weigh in, but I really would leave
that to legal scholars, that judicial review.
What you're talking about with judicial review
is essentially review by the Supreme Court of the
constitutionality of legislative act. So it's sort
of a melding of what are legislative acts carried
out by the House and Senate and the president,
and then comparing and contrasting that with the
Constitution, the Constitution Bill of Rights,
and seeing whether it is coherent with that. And
it is sort of like an ultimate final word in a
sense, on the decisions that are made by our
legislators. And there are people who say, well,
that's really a check and a balance that's
not actually appropriate. And it allows the
Supreme Court to become even political than than
we already know it's allowed to be. I don't have a
strong position as to whether I would get rid of
judicial review. What I'm more interested in is
I think that there are reforms that can be made
to the Supreme Court, including term limits and
creating a pre-determined replacement schedule to
take out the politicization and strategy around
holding on for another year or not. There are
other things that I would like to change about the
Supreme Court, which I've outlined in content on
the show previously, which for me would be lower
hanging fruit than the judicial review question
is really a bigger one, and I'd leave it to the
constitutional law scholars.
Speaker 4: Okay. I completely
understand. And I and I agree with you on
that. The only reason that I bring it up is
it seems like, at least to me and the time that
I've spent on this earth was just very short.
It seems like we have sort of an ontological
problem in this country where we think that like
because something happened a long time ago
and it's been in place for a long time,
that somehow it's better for it.
Speaker 1: Well, that's conservatism
in a nutshell, you know?
Speaker 4: Yeah, it definitely
is. And, you know, I've been reading about
the French republics and the different,
you know, constitutional conventions
that they've had over the years since
they founded their first constitution. And
I just it just so refreshing to hear about
how they've done it and the maturity of
that country. And I just wish we could
do that here. And so we wouldn't have to have
conversations like this where it's like, well,
is one big reform that's not going to happen
Good. Or is a small reform that also probably
won't happen. Is that a good thing? You know?
Speaker 1: No, I completely agree with you. And
I think one of the biggest problems in even having
many serious political conversations in the United
States is a huge contingent that says that just
because it's what was done in the 18th century,
we should, of course, assume that it's the right
way to do things today. You have to break through
that before we can seriously talk about a lot of
different things. But, Christine, I appreciate the
call. Very important elements questioned today.
Speaker 4: Always great to hear from you, David.
Speaker 1: All right. There is Christine from
Washington with a very powerful series of
declarations. Why don't we go next to. Is it safe
or safe from Detroit? Am I saying that correctly?
Safe.
Speaker 4: Yes, it's a safe.
Speaker 1: Safe. Welcome to the program.
Speaker 4: Thank you. Thank you. Sure.
I just wanted to ask you, though,
I don't know if you read recently
a piece for Foreign Affairs about
the Israel-Palestine conflict and
whether the two state solution at this point, I
just wondered if you had any thoughts about that.
Speaker 1: I did not see the article.
You said The article is about what?
Speaker 4: The acoustic solution and basically how
we have to start. Think about the reality of 16.0.
Speaker 1: I have not seen that article. No, I
haven't seen it. I'm a two state solution guy and
I have probably 20 clips on my YouTube channel
about it. So I don't have really any like new
material about it, but I did not see that article.
Speaker 4:
Yeah. Okay. And I just. I just wondering. Hello.
Speaker 1: Okay. Safe. Disappeared.